high-speed trains standing still massive
traffic jams outside Paris
transportation in chaos as strikes run
into the weekend polls showed a strong
majority of French citizens supported
the strike as it began over 800,000
people took part in nationwide protests
on Thursday this widespread popular
discontent with the McCrone government
and pension reforms are always a
difficult sell in this country the
present scheme allows some workers to
retire much earlier than in other
European countries
a popular feature but the government
says changes to the system are necessary
and inevitable citizens know that the
hugely diverse nature of the current 42
pension plans cannot continue the French
people know that one day we'll have to
give up these systems that don't make
sense any more special you know some
pre-completion macro was elected on
promises to make the French economy more
competitive unemployment has come down
but many say they feel a new sense of
uncertainty
they say the proposed pension reforms
are another example of out-of-touch
government policy making but unions risk
losing public support if people get
tired of the disruption caused by the
strikes and demonstrations it's just
another wasted day like yesterday you
can't go to work and you can't go to
school I won't be able to catch up that
annoys me actually disruption is
expected to continue over the weekend
and unions are calling for another day
of mass protests on Tuesday as they test
their mettle against the government and
public patience more on the story we're
joined by Lisa Lewis who's in Paris Lisa
we're seeing another day of nationwide
strikes protests with unions as well as
the yellow vests protesters but things
have been relatively calm until now
haven't they
[Music]
well that's right but as you can see
right behind me there's heavy police
presence here at this demo by the
acidity Union one of the far-left unions
here in France they are demonstrating
against the recent labor market reform
unemployment benefit reform but
obviously also against the pension
reform it's a big picture they say in
mind I call the president they say is
taking apart our Social Security system
security system elsewhere in Paris you
have another demonstration going on by
yellow vest I offered that the yellow
vest protesters try to join this demo
it's their kind of conflicting reports
so some say the police have prevented
them from coming some say they didn't
plan to come but in any case you have
lots of police everywhere here in Paris
and the authorities seem very afraid
that there more clashes today okay now
the trigger for these protests as you
were saying
pension reform president McCulloh says
he's simply trying to simplify france's
notoriously complicated pension system
so why is it people are so angry well
people are really angry and they're
really afraid many people here have told
me you know the plan and memama course
plan is to bring together 42 pension
systems into one single system and they
understand that the current system might
not be sustainable in the long run but
they just don't trust the president to
do the right thing they think that he's
just going to take away from those who
are already struggling to make ends meet
and then then the rich are going to be
even better off and they want today
understand that that the system needs to
be reformed but they don't trust him
through the right thing and they want
him to actually make something happen so
that those who earn less will actually
have more when they retire because some
people are really struggling even today
who do you think will back down first
will it be the protesters or will it be
president mark or
well president McCoy is determined not
to back down he knows that this reform
is crucial for his time in power he
thinks that he needs to carry out the
reform to satisfy his core voters when
he came to power he was appealing to
people from the center-left and people
from the center light right
but now left-wing voters has largely
lost confidence in him and he knows that
he need to satisfy those who are asking
for more reform and that's why even
members from his government say that if
if he doesn't manage to push through
this one the pension reform that he will
have very little chance to get reelected
in 2022 so he doesn't want to drop the
reform but he also knows that if the
strike strike goes on for weeks or even
months that might really have an impact
that he might have to back down so he
knows that he needs to negotiate and
talk to unions and that's what he's
trying to do
the government will unveil the details
of the reform later on next week and
we'll see what they say all right Lisa
Lewis reporting from Paris thanks so
much for bringing us up-to-date